après 8 ans d'attente Magnanville
retrouvée ce matin le départ de la
course cycliste Paris camembert malgré
la grisaille et le départ matinal le
public était nombreux à être venu
soutenir les 16 équipes qui se sont
élancées pour 200 km direction le
Calvados en fin de journée c'était un
beau départ
donc avec des beaux coureurs madois yo
Martin Perez donc je pense ça sera une
belle course et la course a été très
suivie dans la ville qui a vécu au
rythme de Paris camembert entre 1991 et
2014 oui je crois qu'il y a quand même
pas mal de retraités
donc et puis je pense qu'il y a des gens
qui ont fait l'effort aussi de peut-être
de prendre une demi-journée pour venir
parce que je pense que le cyclisme est
un sport qui attire beaucoup beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de de spectateurs ça a
toujours été un public de plus en plus
jeune cette année c'est près de 200
écoliers de la ville qui sont venus ce
matin soutenir les coureurs
si la course compte pour la Coupe de
France de cyclisme l'ambiance est avant
tout convivial et populaire peut avoir
le départ sur le village d'animation
était organisé l'incontournable
dégustation de camembert des ateliers
sur le vélo ainsi que la présentation
des équipes et des séances de dédicace
avec le public
une belle vitrine au niveau de des
Yvelines qui ont déjà effectivement le
départ de Paris Nice donc les Yvelines
c'est une terre de vélo et de ce côté là
on est pas mal gâté une terre de vélo
est plus largement de sport que la
course Paris camembert réaffirme à
l'approche des Jeux de 2024 sur le
territoire